this episode is brought to you by
Shopify Shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever and let's get into it
Shopify is a platform as I mentioned
designed for anyone to sell anything
anywhere giving entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so what does that mean that means in no
time flat you can have a great looking
online store that brings your ideas
products and so on to life and you can
have the tools to manage your day-to-day
business and drive sales this is all
possible without any coding or design
experience whatsoever Shopify instantly
lets you accept all major payment
methods Shopify has thousands of
Integrations and third-party apps from
on-demand printing to accounting to
Advanced chat Bots anything you can
imagine they probably have a way to Plug
and Play and make it happen Shopify is
what I wish I had had when I was
venturing into e-commerce way back in
the early 2000s what they've done is
pretty remarkable I first met the
founder Toby in 2008 when I became an
advisor and it's been in spectacular
I've loved watching Shopify go from
roughly 10 to 15 employees at the time
to 7 000 plus today serving customers in
175 countries with total sales on the
platform exceeding 400 billion dollars
they power millions of entrepreneurs
from their first sale all the way to
full scale and you would recognize a lot
of large companies that also use them
who started small so get started by
building and customizing your online
store again with no coding or design
experience required access powerful
tools to help you find customers Drive
sales and manage your day-to-day gain
knowledge and confidence with extensive
resources to help you succeed and I've
actually been involved with some of that
way back in the day which was awesome
the build a business competition and
other things plus with 24 7 support
you're never alone and let's face it
being an entrepreneur can be lonely but
you have support you have resources you
don't need to feel alone in this case
more than a store Shopify grows with you
and they never stop innovating providing
more and more tools to make your
business better and your life easier go
to shopify.com Tim to sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period it is a
great deal for a great service so I
encourage you to check it out take your
business to the next level today and
learn more by visiting shopify.com Tim
one more time shopify.com Tim all
lowercase
foreign
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep temperature is one of the main
causes of poor sleep and heat is my
personal Nemesis I've suffered for
decades tossing and turning throwing
blankets off pulling the back on putting
one leg on top and repeating all that ad
nauseam but now I am falling asleep in
record time why because I'm using a
device it was recommended to me by
friends called the Pod cover by eight
sleep the Pod cover fits on any mattress
and allows you to adjust the temperature
of your sleeping environment providing
the optimal temperature that gets you
the best night's sleep with the Pod
covers Dual Zone temperature control you
and your partner can set your sides of
the bed to as cool as 55 degrees or as
hot as 110 degrees I think generally in
my experience my partners prefer the
high side and I like to sleep very very
cool so stop fighting this helps based
on your Biometrics environment and sleep
stages the Pod cover makes temperature
adjustments throughout the night that
limit wake-ups and increase your
percentage of deep sleep in addition to
its Best in Class temperature regulation
the Pod cover sensors also track your
health and sleep metrics without the
need to use a wearable so go to
atesleep.com Tim allspelled out
eightsleep.com Tim and save 250 on the
eight sleep pod cover that's
eightsleep.com Tim H sleep currently
ships within the US Canada and the UK
select countries in the EU and Australia
again that's eightsleep.com Tim to save
250 on the eight sleep pod cover optimal
minimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hand
starts shaking
[Music]
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeletons
foreign
s and girls ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show I'm going to keep
this intro short because I am in windy
Wellington New Zealand and it is howling
outside you might hear that in the
background and this is audio verite for
this introduction Dr Kelly Starrett who
is he he's one of my favorite
performance coaches I've spent a lot of
time with him when I have problems other
people cannot solve if I have aches and
pains injuries performance goals perhaps
that people can't spec out for me makes
sense of I call Kelly he's also a
treasure Trove of one-liners and is
hilarious so I think you'll enjoy our
conversation he has been on the podcast
before is very very popular Kelly Star
at DPT you can find him on Twitter and
Instagram at the ready state is along
with his wife Juliet co-founder of the
ready State the ready state began as
mobility wad in 2008 just a side note
Kelly's like 230 pounds of pure muscle
with quads bigger than my chest and he
is more mobile and flexible than I am
full Lotus no problem couch stretch
until you think your hips would explode
no problem so he really walks the talk
and squats the talk as it were all right
so the ready state began as mobility wad
in 2008 and has gone on to transform the
field of performance therapy and
self-care you know I'm gonna keep adding
in little tangents I think it was for
Kelly's 40th birthday he decided and
he'll have to correct me if I get this
wrong that he wanted to do a few things
to celebrate his 40th birthday and Mark
it as a milestone and if my memory
serves me it was a standing backflip
remember the dimensions that I mentioned
it was running an ultra marathon the
quad Dipsy so look that up it is no joke
again remember his physical dimensions
and then power cleaning something like I
have no idea 300 pounds 350 pounds
something outrageous so that is Kelly
Starrett he is the the decathlete of
power and Mobility so let's get back to
the bio his clients include professional
athletes in the NFL NBA NHL and MLB
that's Major League Baseball for folks
outside of the US he also works with
Olympic gold medalists Tour de France
cyclists world and national record
holding Olympic lifting and power
athletes CrossFit Games medalists
professional ballet dancers Elite
military personnel and much more Kelly
is the author of The New York Times and
Wall Street Journal bestsellers becoming
a Supple Leopard and ready to run his
new book is built to move subtitled the
10 essential habits to help you move
freely and live fully co-written with
Juliet starrette so her name has come up
a few times now and I've known Juliet
for a long time who is Juliet I just
have to mention a few things before we
move on so Juliet trained as an attorney
she's done a million different things
badass in business incredible operator
but also she was the U.S national
champion being in extreme White Water
racing from 1997 to 2000 world champion
from 97 to 98 she returned to the sport
in 2018 to become world champion in the
Masters division so she is also very
smart very capable very fit and both of
them as a team have really thought
through what it takes to build yourself
to move so you can find all things
related to them at the readystate.com
all one word and without further Ado
please enjoy this wide ranging
conversation with Dr Kelly starratt
Kelly
that's too bad my friend
[Music]
we are sitting we're sitting emphasis on
sitting yeah we're very low to the
ground we have a table in front of us
that is about
let's call it 12 inches 14 inches off of
the ground which means we received it on
the floor
and under some very thin mats we have
Tommy mats and that is because we are in
Japan not only in Japan we're in the
Northern Ireland Hokkaido of Japan
looking outside we have
snow-covered mountains and we are in a
Japanese style room
what else would you like to say about
this particular trip to Japan an
experience in Japan
well I have this friend named Tim who
sometimes drags me on Wild Goose chases
and it's become a feature of my life
where I have to ask myself am I capable
enough to go have fun on an adventure
with Tim
so here we are after a week of I've done
a lot of intense things this is very
intense we were skiing in steep snow
it's back country skiing we're climbing
mountains and skiing down
it's very cold and very vigorous
and I've also found myself in the first
time ever I'm the oldest person on the
trip and I have all these young friends
who are like I cut off your arm and it
regrows the next day
now I should use that as a segue
yesterday when we're climbing this
mountain and I guess with wind chills
probably
I want to say probably negative 10
Fahrenheit something like that easily it
was very very very very the coolest game
I've ever had extremely cold and we are
skinning up the mountain which means for
those people who don't know because I
certainly didn't know a few years ago
you have your skis they are slick on the
bottom that's what helps you go down the
mountain but if you try to put on your
skis and go up the mountain you don't
get anywhere because you slide backwards
well back in the day I believe it was
seal skin hence the name skins were used
on the bottom of skis by indigenous
populations to go uphill because the
hair is matted down in One Direction
kind of like Blades of grass that have
been heavily blown in One Direction
which means if they're placed correctly
on the bottom of the ski can catch and
you wouldn't imagine this would work
that the physics of this would work no
actually it would be fun yeah but it
does and so you can basically really
slide one ski next to the other and use
special touring boots and bindings that
allow your heel to come up so you can
slide your way up the mountain and the
ratio for those wandering is what would
you say six hours up to every six turns
down I'm exaggerating but it's it's a
lot of work is the juice worth the
squeeze and I would say in this
particular case since we were all
completely buried in
unearthly light powder and when I say
buried I mean friends were over their
heads in powder just plowing through let
me sleep yeah when the ski guides say
powder of the year yeah best run of the
year I've never experienced anything
like it yeah and so if you're if you're
going at reasonably high speed through
Waist Deep powder it is going to go over
your head in your face you're going to
get face shots which is a good thing in
this case and the reason I bring it up
is number one just to paint a picture
for folks with respect to why we're here
in Northern Japan why would you fly all
the way across any pond because it's an
island so you're going to be flying here
over some form of water to ski and the
answer is the pattern is unlike anything
anyone on this trip is ever seen it's
unbelievable however on the way up
you're exerting a lot and you're exposed
to the elements and I was thinking
yesterday it's like wow
I'm 45 and if I had posed the question
of my 20 year old self do you think at
age 45 that you would ever be able to do
this I think the answer would have been
no
probably I think the 20 year old self
would have had very very low confidence
and that made me happy to think about I
was like yeah I got some aches and pains
and as you know I have some pain in the
right lower back and when you're on
steep inclines really working all of
that hip musculature and the psoas and
everything else is like oh I'm really
feeling it but nonetheless was able to
do it and we're having Onsen meaning hot
springs and cold baths and the contrast
of hot cold hot colds and the food is
pretty like if you're gonna do this
thing day after day look I'm going to
say that getting hot getting cold eating
like rice and meat yeah and then going
to bed very early we're all sleep
deprived it's worked
every day I think to myself well that
was it and the next morning I have I am
resurrected and I'm like okay well let's
go see how we feeling it's been really
just remarkable how much time have you
spent in Japan overall this is going to
tie into the broader conversation we're
going to have folks just so
I'm laying the table a bit I want to
tell you what I'm doing but how much
time have you spent in Japan that's 100
zero so let's call it roughly week
what are some of the things you've
observed in terms of Japan in terms of
let's just say this hotel which is a
reasonably especially with your
particular room that we're sitting in
very traditional Hotel what have you
noticed in the lounge area what's
different about the lounge area keeping
in mind also that at least half the
people here maybe 70 80 percent are
probably 70 years
old or older yes so imagine a world
around you where you come into a really
fancy will come Mountain Lodge and it's
not fancy this is like a mountain lodge
where people are coming on vacation
and you take your shoes off at the door
and you walk around
slippery wood floors and socks and
they're everyone serving staff wait
staff front staff it doesn't matter your
age you're cruising on slippery floors
in socks
so already it's remarkable to see sort
of the balance required the your foot is
contacted the ground people are really
uncomfortable Barefoot and the first
thing you notice when you come in is
everyone is Barefoot serving Barefoot
acting Barefoot and it changes how you
move how quickly you move it's very
interesting to just perceive that and
that's just that's a door what's
interesting is it reminds me
how much we cueing we take from our
environment and really honestly how
quickly I've adapted to I talk about
this a lot but the environment shapes Us
in subtle and unsubtle ways and quickly
within a week I have been shaped Again
by my environment in a whole 180 yeah
and if you go to the lounge on the
second floor which is the main hang area
for the entire building which at full
capacity probably holds at least a few
hundred people I would think maybe 300
people and it's an active area the vast
majority of tables are just like this
and if you want to sit down there's a
stack of mats and you get your mat which
is maybe half inch to an inch thick and
you sit on the floor and that is just
how it works and nobody complains
because they're accustomed to it and
everyone can do it everyone can do it
everyone can do it and I remember when I
was 15
first in Japan as an exchange student my
first trip out of the US really of any
type was a year as an exchange student
and
I went to a baseball game with a high
school friend and all the toilets were
squat toilets so for people who haven't
used these I mean there's basically a
hole in the ground it's clean I mean
it's porcelain but you squat down and
your ass is basically on your heels and
that is how you do your business and I
remember asking him how do old people do
this don't they fall over and he laughed
and he said they're used to it they've
done it their entire lives so I would
imagine
net net that there are more people in
the U.S who can clean and jerk and
snatch and press heavy weight overhead
but that if a facet of functional
fitness is sitting on the ground
for a half hour without having to fidget
non-stop because there's some issue
biomechanically that is making you
uncomfortable that Japan wins hands down
wins the U.S
it should be noted just the body is so
simple use it or lose it and I think
imagine all the complexity that we have
to program and come to this functional
fitness class
to solve the issues of you not sitting
on the ground and pooping on the ground
sleeping on the ground we've created a
we have a whole construct to remedy the
fact that you're not doing things that
people have been doing all the time and
I'm not pining for our Paleolithic cells
I don't need to you know fermented whale
carcass I don't need that I'm stoked
that we've moved Beyond
but it is interesting that built into
the environment here are some truths
around your body there's a great writer
named Philip Beach who wrote a book
called muscles and meridians really
wonderful book but he thinks that one of
the ways the body Tunes itself is
actually sitting on the ground hips get
reset because you're kneeling you're
putting fashion into certain positions
you're maintaining key ranges of motion
all you have to do is sit on the ground
and we used to sit toilet eat hang out
celebrate sleep just we were just
interacting on the ground and all of a
sudden that's gone
and so it really begets this interesting
question of how much more complexity are
we having to always add in when there's
a mismatch or not even mismatch but
we've made certain choices about the way
our environment shapes us yeah and we
were chatting earlier today and I just
said I've been to Japan as an adult
not that many times with groups of
non-japanese but maybe two three times
I've been yeah let's call it three times
maybe four in any case the number
doesn't really matter what matters is in
every single trip
if we walked into a Japanese restaurant
the chorus of the group would say oh God
I hope there are chairs because
in each group even if these people are
overall very very athletic
I would say
70 to 80 percent would not be able to
sit on the ground for more than five
minutes without getting
very uncomfortable fidgety yeah or
finding something to lean back against
as we talk about this and this is where
I thought we would be led in the
conversation is singing about
environmental modification or
what your sheep diet might be hmm that's
really good right yeah it's like okay if
you do intermittent fasting X number of
times per week like maybe you spend
one day per week sitting on the ground
you somehow modify your environment or
your behavior just to incorporate some
of these older more common shaves the
broader question I suppose could be and
I know this is something you've thought
a lot about are how we might think of
Vital Signs right so if anybody goes
into
see their general practitioner for an
annual checkup or they go into the ER
first thing they're going to do
is take a couple of measurements and
it's standardized for a lot of good
reasons so they're going to check your
blood pressure they're going to check
your heart rate maybe they'll check your
blood oxygen saturation with pulse ox
they're a handful of things that they
will check
how do you think about vital signs as it
pertains to your areas of expertise now
and part of the reason I enjoy hanging
out with you and chatting is that you do
not have a
static
repertoire or model for thinking about
these things as we've talked over the
years I've seen it
evolve and change and be informed by new
experiences and new observations so how
do you think about
Vital Signs I'll keep it broad if we
take the allegory for where we are right
now we're sitting getting up and down
off the ground without using your hand
just being able to sit crisscross
applesauce and lower yourself and stand
up without having to put your hands down
our knee down
turns out is a really excellent
predictor of morbidity and mortality so
you can do this wherever you are no
knees no hands means getting into a
squatting position no cross-legged okay
so you don't even have to have full hip
flexion you don't have to squat you can
be on the outside of your feet how
strong you need to be able to do this I
don't know if children can do it I've
seen some elderly Japanese people do
this pretty effortlessly they're not
that jacked you know they're not on the
Gale hatch Squad program so there's
something that this with your knee out
to the side and crisscross is a real
mid-range position but if you can't Flex
forward in this position to shift your
weight and push up on that you'll
discover really quickly you're like wow
having a hard time getting up off the
ground does that mean that you're not an
elite athlete no does that mean you're
you know you can't live in your Society
no but it means that hey there's
something going on with your ability to
move freely that may be reducing your
likelihood of having movement choice or
feeling better and now what we've done
is begin to have a greater conversation
about if we can help you restore or you
can ReStore in your own home how your
hips move and how easily you can move
you might feel better and be less likely
to fall and be more independent the
number one reason people end up in
nursing homes can't get above ground by
themselves I've fallen and I can't get
up that's right you know this I'm just
thinking so folks can Envision this
right you're sitting cross-legged on the
ground can you get up without using a
hand on the ground not posting and it
gave me a flashback because
coach Christopher summer used to be the
U.S national gymnastics team coach
had me at one point training quite
intensely this is probably five years
ago
and one of the key exercises that he
used for his athletes to not just work
on broader Mobility let's just say but
specifically on lateral
knee strength and I suppose lateral leg
strength would be more accurate he would
have people do basically this exactly so
they would be in a cross-legged position
they'd come down
then they would lift themselves back up
rotate 180 degrees so the legs are in
the opposite position let's just say in
terms of stacking lower down get up and
then rinse and repeat just as
repetitions in a controlled fashion so
you're not just dropping your ass to
this it's not the time yeah yeah exactly
and
I hadn't connected these two even at
home in in Austin it's not like I sit on
the ground across like that often I mean
I do but not as much as I have on this
trip in Japan certainly and how much
that helped not just durability but also
performance
suppose what comes to mind I'd be
curious to hear your thoughts is that if
you aim for a certain degree of
durability and you're getting your ABCs
in terms of shape vitamins and you're
ensuring that you can do things like you
just described getting off the ground
with your likes cross like that leads
into performance those things will
almost certainly all Aid
performance in some capacity or make it
more sustainable but not necessarily the
other way around right like you can be a
one-trick pony for a performance
standpoint
but it will not necessarily contribute
let's just say in one movement pattern
you're spectacularly good I'm interested
in archery right now it's like okay
you're really good at archery
asymmetrically on one side but that does
not mean when you are 70 that you are
going to
have full health span and be able to do
the things you want to do but if you
focus on the durability those should I
would imagine contribute to
a lot of different performance goals I'm
bringing up a really good point is that
we have come to appreciate because again
we have really smart friends we're in
really interesting communities trying to
solve some of these problems of The
Human Condition if you look at our first
book becoming us up a leopard
there's really two key objective
measurable repeatable explainable ideas
there one is range of motion native
range of motion this is what every
physician every surgeon every physical
therapist all agrees your shoulders
should be able to do it's not you have
to be a gymnast but there's some basic
ranges that it's endemic to every human
so let's just get back to that
second is biomotor output which is a
fancy way of saying wattage well we have
poundage like what we saw was that if we
could restore your range of motion
and teach towards the highest expression
of our formal movements we saw that you
could go faster and win World
Championships now all the behaviors that
we got interested in around supporting
those two things meant we had to sort of
start to care about sleep we had to
start to care about
micronutrients and are getting enough
protein are you decongesting your body
through walking
so in service of high performance we
have
what we've come to call Base Camp
behaviors and it's shocking how many
world-class athletes
we come in contact with who are really
good let's say the best in the world and
this is not hyperbole really
extraordinary mutants who are very
thoughtful but have big holes in their
understanding of their process they can
go do that thing but their sleep isn't
great or they don't eat enough
carbohydrate or like you can just
whatever just for the individual person
but it turns out I like this analogy of
the spinning coin I think it's an idle
portal he left them I heard him talk
about it is that the other side of that
coin is these are the behaviors that
make a durable person independent of
performance and so you get to care about
being a hundred years old and moving the
way you want to be Juliet has this great
idea she's like look you probably do
some goal setting as a human if you're a
business like you're like working
there's our first quarter goal here's
what we're doing when have you done that
for your life what does it look like
what do you imagine your life look like
to be 70 people like Financial Security
I'm like okay but what does it look like
in your environment Peter Tia had this
centenarian games concept which I think
is really elegant but let me go a step
further because a lot of those things
were metrics around like I want to be
able to put a kettlebell out in front of
me and squat that was like one of those
or like lift a grandchild right at at
100 therefore I need to work backwards
what should my so let's just take that
and then let's go ahead and expand on
that idea and start to say well what are
the key the vital signs that illuminate
what behaviors create that reality so
instead of just saying well I'm just
going to go around with children excuse
me ma'am can I pick up your child which
can get you there we can start to say do
you have the components and what are
those components and more importantly
how do I fit them into my crazy schedule
because that is the thing so what are
some base cap behaviors what are some
important base camp behaviors you know
none of them end up being very sexy
here's the caveat so it's hard to
commoditize these things hard to charge
for these things and more importantly
and I'm being facetious but these are
things that are easily done in your home
by you controlling control you don't
need a physical therapist or a physician
or anyone else to come in and give you
these things that's I think really
important we see that the functional
unit of getting anything done in your
family in your life and your health is
in your house you so we could start by
took some behavioral ones we might say
like sleep is a good one I think this is
good because one of the things that
I think is hidden from a lot of people
is how tightly coupled or connected our
behaviors are so let's take sleeping and
walking for example does everyone agree
you should sleep more
sure okay sounds good good carry on
what's going on we see that the Sleep
data is that people don't sleep and that
they need a lot of help and it's a big
business to help people to sleep more so
what we've tried to do is say things
like hey look seven hours of sleep is
very reasonable for survival and if
you're trying to change your body
composition I want to get skinnier
leaner I'm trying to grow muscles I'm
trying to learn a skill of a growing
body or I'm trying to heal I need to get
eight plus hours of sleep in order to
facilitate the maximum adaptation and to
really make it easier for my body do
that and I started really becoming
obsessed about this one is that we
started to learn in high performance
that if you can't sleep you can't
perform I don't talk about one bad night
of sleep before the big game that's what
I'm talking about but we started to see
that when we improve sleep and more
importantly start tracking sleep and
really putting that as something we
cared about we started seeing
Improvement into performance and then
swung around
to my work in persistent pain and
chronic pain that one of the big holes
when people had persistent pain and
chronic pain was their sleep and you
might not be able to sleep for a whole
host of reasons relative to your
persistent pain and chronic pain but
when we were able to improve your sleep
density your brain stopped to be less
sensitive about and you had more desire
to move and maybe you had less pain
sensitivity so everyone's like growing
kids need to sleep but adults we don't
so if we take that sleep idea now we
have we have a benchmark seven hours for
survival eight hours for doing something
that it's important to me that means
that I need to start thinking about some
of the behaviors in the day to make that
happen so we come back into walking I
think it was debunked that ten thousand
steps is the magic number well the
research now the people who study these
things are saying somewhere between six
and eight thousand steps is like really
good for your health one of the things
we learned from some of our friends in
these tier one military groups who have
really struggled with sleep think of the
Ninjas in the Army for example the one
of the first things that was being
prescribed when trying to untangle this
gordian knot was they would increase the
step count of the people walking or
people that they're working with so
pushing to ten thousand pushing twelve
thousand pushing to fifteen thousand
steps and what those people were
exercising but they weren't getting
enough non-exercise activity so suddenly
here we have this Society who's cued not
to walk
where my shape my work where I park the
whole thing is that I just maybe get two
or three thousand steps a day your
iPhone actually has a step counter and
you probably have your phone with you
open up your health and it'll tell you
what your Trends is this is in the
background watching how much you're
walking you're welcome you have a step
counter probably you're carrying with
you didn't know you had
but one of the things we know is that if
we can get people to improve their step
count we also start to see that they
accumulate enough sleep stress sleep
pressure is the technical term but then
they want to fall asleep and again
they're experts here on sleep I'm not
trying to be I'm just saying we need to
change how you're thinking about your
movement in the day
so you can actually fall asleep
and it turns out when you get a good
night's sleep you wake up and you what
happens you feel more like moving and
those behaviors suddenly become tightly
coupled or tightly linked and I don't
think sometimes we can appreciate how
these seemingly pink Shea silly
non-technical things can really make a
big change and if we start to put those
in play if you just committed to walking
more every day say just say minimum
threshold let's say 8 000 steps right I
just want to get eight thousand whatever
that means that means you need to get 10
minute walks after every meal however
you're going to do it just get more
steps than you're doing
and you start doing that run that for a
week and let me know what happens to
your skin and how your Consciousness and
do you need that four o'clock coffee
month and it's shocking when we start to
help people do these base camp behaviors
again why do I care about this because I
want you to win a world championship
also I want you to be 100 years old and
and enjoy it yeah
the Sleep conundrum right for me which
has also been a guardian knot but it
turns out that a lot of the for me
biggest levers are so [__] simple I
love to solve complex problems because I
think I have some predisposition to
being good at it so I tend to insert
complexity sometimes where it's not
needed and right like people raise my
I'm raising my hand I totally agree it's
much cooler to be on the Secret Squirrel
sleep program if you can problem solve
you get rewarded and you get positive
reinforcement so you look for problems
to solve but sometimes
the the problem is actually just
tic-tac-toe it's not three-dimensional
chess and with it's like on this trip
has anyone on this trip had trouble
falling asleep doing
has one stayed up past 9 30. yeah no no
I just suck yeah just go climb Mountain
for five hours a day and you will fall
asleep now it doesn't need to be that
extreme though at home I noticed for
instance in Austin I was having trouble
sleeping for a week or so and I was like
you know what
trying all the supplements I'm trying
all the cues and doing all the things
and it seems like 17 disparate elements
why don't I just disallow myself from
sitting down and working at a computer I
will only use my laptop if I'm on a
treadmill desk and got a relatively
cheap treadmill desk nothing fancy
pretty easy to stow away and lo and
behold it's like if you're standing and
walking
for almost every minute that you're on
your laptop you fall asleep really
easily I became hyper obsessed with
walking because it's elite no because
one of the things we found is not only
did it improve the sleep of the people
you're working with but we also found
that we had healthier tissue quality
so everyone we're going back to Anatomy
you're going back to your early
physiology in high school you have a
circulatory system and you have this
lymphatic system so if you ever had a
blister that's lymph your lymphatic
system is the sewage system of your body
and this doesn't just there when you
have injuries and something swells
and by the way your joints are drained
by the Deep lymphatic system
but you can think of them as highways
that carry the normal sewage and waste
products of your body the cells turning
over proteins breaking down things that
are too big to go through your
bloodstream go through your lymphatic
system those lymphatic vessels are
buried into your musculature and they're
one-way valves into passive systems so
how do you move
your sewage through your body it turns
out it's muscle contraction you're like
that's a really clever system it's
almost like when we came to be someone's
like you know what these people move a
lot let's just put the sewage system in
the movement system and so suddenly if
you're doing the walking you are
decongesting and you're bringing the
garbage out and bringing the groceries
in and if you've seen a drain this is
from one of our friends Perry Nicholson
if you've seen a drain in a bathtub it
doesn't drain it gets backed up and it's
kind of gross that's your body if you
don't move you can Elevate sure that
feels good you can compress you can get
into the the compression boots you can
do all the lymphatic massage you can or
wait for you can walk around a little
bit more so one of the things we found
was that our athletes were having better
recovery scores because they were able
to move the serious waste products of
exercise we're doing a lot of
adaptational stress when we train and we
found that they had healthier tissue
issues and more importantly when tissues
were injured because remember sometimes
I get that lens right I see everyone's
broken parts and bits through sport
how do we manage a swollen ankle well we
can compress it we can elevate it and we
can move it sorry I'm just smirking
because the number of times people have
been like Kelly Dr Kelly fixed me on
this trip I'm like oh man didn't know
Kelly was coming on a work trip but
anyway it's all I think about and I'm
gonna need you to dig me out of that
snow pit so
suddenly
all of if we want to say hey I want to
have joints that are normal and again
not normal isn't good or bad but just
typical try not to get that language
then decongestion is a way that you can
actually adapt to exercise more
effectively so if you are smashing
yourself on the Peloton because that's
what your life demands you are such a
crazy working parent busy business owner
you're getting it in high five yourself
but then you figured out well wait a
minute maybe I can actually adapt to the
stress a little bit more by walking
perching which is leaning up against the
stool valid working fidget move stand
you don't have to stand like a robot sit
a little bit stand a little bit fidget
but one of the things we know is that if
you're smashing yourself and then not
continuing to move you're going to see
congestion if you've ever flown on an
airplane which I did and I got off the
airplane in Japan and I was like look I
have cankles this is not a good look I I
have gigantic cankles and that cankelage
is you not Contracting your calf to move
the congestion so your tissues are being
congested because you've been inactive
so long and then you're like oh is that
the source of dvts yes it is right deep
Vin thrombosis yes or so suddenly you're
like oh for some population we can see
that this could be really dangerous
dangerous if you've ever been in the
hospital they're like put on these boots
they're squeezer calves and then oh yeah
ankle pumps you're not gonna do all the
ankle pumps everyone who has ever had a
any surgery or injuries like ankle pumps
ankle pumps ankle pumps well what is
that about it's about pumping out the
garbage so now we have another reason to
move around a little bit more and more
importantly if you're a busy person
I can tell you how you can work this
intense training because we're training
like maniacs I think the training that
people are doing today is gnarlier more
people are doing harder training than
they were 10 years ago more than they're
20 years ago and we may not have set up
our lives or have the capacity in our
lives to manage those training stressors
as effective as we could if you can just
kind of keep the engine idling a little
bit standing desk fidgeting perching
moving around a little more movement
choice you will adapt and have healthier
tissues that can take more load more
often
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
ag1 by athletic greens I get asked all
the time what I would take if I could
only take one supplement the answer is
invariably ag1 I view it as my
all-in-one nutritional insurance I
recommended it long ago in my 2010
number one New York Times bestseller the
four hour body and I did not get paid to
do so with approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient dense formula on
the market it has a multivitamin a
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and immune
support formula digestive enzymes and
adaptogens ag-1 makes it easy to get a
lot of nutrition when good Whole Foods
simply aren't at hand or when you just
want to ensure you are covering your
bases ag-1 is the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle in one
easy scoop and athletic greens is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first subscription purchase go to
athleticgreens.com Tim you can check it
out athleticgreens.com Tim they also
offer a 90-day money-back guarantee if
you are not 100 satisfied learn more try
it out athleticgreens.com Tim
what are some more I don't want to say
pass fail tests but
experiments that people can do with
Vital Signs so we talked about one which
is the cross-legged on the floor can you
get up
and can you get down for that matter
right into that position everyone can
get down usually to the ground well no
one time yeah yeah so that's one what
are some others here's one that I think
we're really interested in and it's
balance we like to talk about balance
because any young person I'm like here's
what you're gonna do on Tuesday you're
going to go to a balance class you're
not going to lift weights you're not
gonna do a sport you're gonna go into a
balanced class you're like the hell I am
going to a balanced class
that's for old people so one of the
things that we have come to appreciate
even more is that this balance system
it's crucial to humans moving can I
pause for a second we learned this
yesterday the scariest part for me of
the entire program which was pretty
[__] gnarly I mean when we got up
there hey your word's not mine but yeah
but the scariest part for me was there
were multiple stream slash River
Crossings where there was like a pirate
plank that's about that's generous yeah
generous like 12 inches across maybe 10
inches covered in snow and ice and into
a snow bank that you get to climb up and
you have to right exactly and you have
to get across that in your ski boots
without falling several feet into this
Century deprivation coffins
and I realized wow I really have fear
around my lateral balance
even though oddly enough maybe you can
tell me why this is the case I'm much
more comfortable on a slack line than I
am on say a balance beam I have a lot of
trouble with balancing and I've torn a
lot of stuff in my lower legs and ankles
but I have thought quite a bit around
where this telescopes to longitudinally
if I don't deal with it yeah I'm like
okay this is already
fear inducing Juliet's mother is a good
example who is so active and you've been
on the Grand Canyon with Juliet's father
he's very active but about 10 or 15
years ago Juliet's mom just said I'm not
riding a bike anymore I don't feel safe
and guess what I trust her that she
suddenly has said this is outside my
scope of experience where I feel like I
can recover that's a balanced task
so we can either do what we've always
done is wait until someone Falls and
then be like oh we should work on your
balance which works we're going to now
go to physical therapy and do balance
training we started to really focus on
and performance side bear with me
everyone this intrinsic feeling of your
foot pressure during your these complex
movements kettlebell swings air squats
basketball power whatever
we really realized that if we could get
people feeling what was going on their
feet we corrected a whole bunch of
Downstream movement perturbation things
that we would used to have a whole bunch
of Corrections for right oh the bar path
is going here or this is happening or
now you need to shove your knee out but
if I just said hey here's where your
ball of your foot is and here's your
heel and keep your ankle in the middle
best you can just organized foot let's
see if we can challenge that with all
the things we're already doing exercise
and it means that it translates to like
real world balance I'm gonna stand on
this beam I want to pick up stand up
paddling I I need to be better on my
feet
and really the interesting question then
comes to
when and where do you do this it turns
out that we saw the balance was a
performance hack and in fact my favorite
thing in balance training
I discovered in your garage and one of
the things I discovered there was this
really cool thing called a slack block
and it was like a portable slack line
and immediately I was like Tim is a
genius he's figured this thing out
where I don't have to have a slack line
but I can play with my balance I can
challenge my balance in my kitchen it's
the size of like a large brick yeah yeah
but it's squishy and I was just like oh
Tim Ferriss you I'm like bummed out that
I didn't know about this and you've like
brought this thing to my life because
what I found out was I could stack give
those to my athletes like candy and be
like when you're making coffee stand on
this okay when I'm on Zoom calls I am
working my foot strength and balance
so here's another Vital sign please
where you can say hey maybe I need to
work on this maybe I need to brush my
teeth and my eyes closed or stand on one
leg
you should be able to stand on one foot
easily for 20 seconds without putting
your foot down and if there's a
difference left to right maybe because
you got injured on that side or you do a
certain thing on that side that's okay
you know where you can figure this out
very quickly so this year ski boot
Slackline yes
I'll keep it Slackline Franken Slack
skiing so this year I have skied and
this is I mean it's taken some planning
and a lot of commitment and moving
things around but to really say Okay I
want to do a really proper ski season
for the first time in my life and that
was this year it has been I mean it's
still going and when you start trying to
move around on skis not just going
downhill but skating
say on flat ground or even uphill
holy cow do you realize what asymmetries
you may have or turning One Direction
versus the other and what you end up
doing with your upper body it's been an
incredible
diagnostic tool for me and I'm not
saying I'm not saying everyone should
use skiing this way because I realize
skiing is not the cheapest sport to deal
with but becoming more familiar with
like foot pressure as real ramifications
in skiing
and boot pressure right it's like if
you're leaning back if you're in your
heels versus weight on the toes versus
weight on the mid foot versus weight on
the inside of the midfoot save for
edging
it's been really really eye-opening for
me and while trying to skate which for
people who are trying to Envision this I
mean just imagine that you're ice
skating but you have skis on which means
it's a lot easier to trip over yourself
and it's a lot easier to fall over an
outside edge you just have kind of
different lever arms and so on and no
ankle range of motion yeah and no ankle
Arrangement motion I was like wow I'm
really really asymmetrically cover must
and that's okay yeah that we have one
side that's more dominant you
professional skateboarder you drive a
car with your right foot it doesn't
matter what the mechanisms you tore your
ACL in high school it doesn't matter
what matters is that you can become
conscious of it and then think well what
are the things that are in my control so
you turn skating into a diagnostic tool
into a Vital sign as soon as you're
aware then you can start to connect the
dots all these other places can I tell
you yeah what ended up happening so what
what ended up happening which I was only
able to spot with video review which is
not that hard folks it's like everybody
has a video recorder called a phone now
so I had someone record me from downhill
we looked at it together and what came
of it was very simple it's like oh
you're really kind of winging one of
your polls up when you take this weaker
turn and so I try to keep the poll down
meaning keep the basket the bottom of
the pole dragging on the ground and as
soon as I did that I was like oh
that's a lot easier and now I can
actually work on that weak side without
as much fear involved so for this type
of Vital sign 20 seconds
on each foot is that the it's called the
soleck that's the 120 over 80. yep the
the solac it's standing one leg eyes
closed solo Oh the eyes closes that adds
something it adds something and what we
find is that when people are over
reliant on their vision and not their
sort of intrinsic other vestibular
systems other sort of input systems then
when you start to lose that this is why
falling in the evening is a big problem
for people of the night because they're
over dependent on their their like the
fixation point with vision so it turns
out way for it improving your ankle
range of motion means you have better
reaction when you get outside of your
base of support yeah and suddenly you're
you're like oh that foot strength and
Ankle range of motion means that I can
write myself more quickly the brain is
very clear about you can do this you
can't do this you have access to this
position I can open up and unlock the
next level for you if you don't your
movement Solutions start to be
diminished and pruned in your brain so
when we start to give people inputs and
improve their inputs the brain starts to
say oh when you're falling or you're
outside of this space of support we can
start to give you movement Solutions and
movement options to this perturbation in
the system
I want you to correct me if I'm wrong
and also I'll also name the auditory
pink elephant in the room so we've we've
decided to take today as a rest day
prior to extremely long international
travel what that means is we are one of
the few people in our rooms while the
wonderful house cleaning crew is going
to town so if you hear anything it's not
Ghosts no poltergeists it's just
cleaning going on there's a lot of
cleaning that happens in Japan it is
immaculate chances are the public
bathroom at the bus stop not kidding is
cleaner than your bathroom at home very
very high probability 100 in fact
there's been several times in your life
Kelly
you need to come check out this washroom
oh yeah I've said it multiple times like
Kelly it's your first time here
go to this public bathroom tell me that
look I I trust you on so many levels you
haven't been wrong
this bathroom is amazing uh so just
mentioning that but what I was going to
say is and I I haven't looked at the
literature for this but just from
observation I would say it your body
will not allow you to operate right up
to the edge of your established comfort
zone whether that's vestibular on the
balance side or on say the flexibility
slash strength side and we have a friend
on this trip I'm not going to mention it
by name because I don't want to
incriminate him but he is
extremely athletic taller and lackier
I'll just say that and very successful
former competitive athlete
and Incredibly inflexible and it's
become more and more of a problem as he
has gotten older and the recommendation
that he typically gets and this is not
to paint with too broad a brush because
I know there are many different types of
yoga but the recommendation that he gets
most is you need to stretch more and I
did one and I'm gonna get ridiculed by
some people for this but I'll tell you
before you ridicule it
try it which is go going to a very very
very technical hard ass Pilates
instructor for love greatness personal
instruction
is uh
it's I find it just incredibly impactful
Joseph Pilates was not messing about
yeah yeah he was not messing around and
so I took this friend to that class and
what we both noticed and this is not a
miracle I think it's just the way that
things work is as he became more
comfortable at his end range of motion
and as he started to gain strength in
that end range of motion voila suddenly
the body's like okay now I'm not afraid
of you breaking
us therefore I will allow you an
additional say two inches of hang in the
yoga class but it came from
strengthening at the end ranges of
movement not just stretching more
passively right and so I have to imagine
balance works that way too
very much the brain is looking for
inputs to perceive the world as safe or
unsafe that's a really simple way of
looking at it
the first thing we can think about is
where we want is we talked about sleep
we want to add in these complex
Solutions the first order of business is
to spend time in the positions you're
trying to improve and not do an end
range like things spend time in the end
range so if you're sitting on the ground
and it's uncomfortable
the first thing we should do is start to
get you to start sitting on the ground
more it's that simple so tonight
just get off the couch
we love TV in our house we love it we
love these things so clever it's a way
that we like chill in the evening we sit
on the floor in front of the couch the
English as many times as I've
recommended you go check out a Japanese
bathroom you've recommended that I watch
the English I've not seen it folks
however and labeling it so automatic
it's excellent recommend I'm not being
paid but I've only blunt to say this
everyone is excellent so if you just sit
on the floor you're going to take some
of your tissues to end range and you're
long sitting is just sitting out with
your legs in front of you do you
remember to sit and reach test in middle
school yeah yeah that's long-sitting so
we're actually going to train for the
test we're going to train by the test
just by making sure that you're exposed
there
one of my I think you've maybe even you
know who he is great cook SMS has this
old saying I'm sure he cripped from my
anger if you can't breathe in a position
you don't own that position so the first
order of business is getting you to the
end range shape are you best of your
ability today because remember your
range of motion and capacity moves a
moving Target just run a marathon jump
on an airplane have a newborn and let's
just test your hamstring range of motion
it's gonna be awful and so what we want
to do is we want a more tightly conjoin
our day-to-day processes with
understanding who we are you don't have
to go skate on your skis every day but
sitting on the ground every day you can
be like whoa this side sitting is tough
today I'll just do here and I'll spend
enough time here they have to take some
breaths here so when we come back to
balance one of the easiest things to do
is figure out ways where we can begin to
expose it in a native way that you don't
have to do another thing everyone who's
listening to this you have some
go-getters my friends listen they are
killing their lives but I'm like here's
a list of 10 more things to add on
they're like thank you no thank you so
for example we have this friend named
Chris Henshaw who's a great coach and he
discovered this thing called putting
your shoes on
[Music]
and he wanted to create a test that he
could beat his kids at so he called it
the old man test and all you have to do
is stand on one leg
use your hands bend over pick up your
sock without putting the other foot down
put on your sock on one leg and then put
on your shoe all standing one leg that's
all you have to do so it's like a
it's like a single leg deadlift
old man if you want to solve it that way
you can I don't really care how you want
to solve it you want to come into a
pistol you want to hinge you want to do
some kind of weird side caustic squat
like it doesn't matter stand on one leg
put your sock on and then reach down
with your hand pick up your shoe push it
on and you can cross your legs to do it
you can put your knee to your chest but
you'll be shocked and really what's
amazing there is instead of just static
balance you're being moving and having
to control it and you're going to make
mistakes and some days guess what you're
going to be terrible at it because
you're burnt you're over trained you're
fraught you're stressed
so with balance specifically I've always
wondered this like what is the minimum
effective dose for improving balance
because testing balance is one thing
improving it may be another I don't know
enough about it there's a neural
component there is a vestibular
component so if the hardware in your
inner ear and so on is damaged then
you're probably going to be compromised
or just H stiff or just H then there are
the sort of muscular coordination pieces
a lot of components of this there are
lots there's a lot so if I just want to
go in and I've got I want bigger lats I
want then I know how to say we are I
know how to do that right like go in and
there are a million and one ways to do
it but if you have it let's just take a
very very simple example if you want to
do one set to failure it's like okay let
me try to get I'm not saying this is a
perfect look 100 seconds under tension
to failure okay great and you do that
you wait a week chances are your lats
are going to get bigger especially if
you're sedentary and you just don't have
a lot of lifting experience what does
that look like for improving
balance I'd say and I guess it depends
on your weaknesses like which Link in
that chain is weakest but I I wouldn't
even know how to dissect that
necessarily and maybe we don't Maybe
we could start by saying is there any
time in your day-to-day life regularly
where you're challenging your balance
yeah so you're like I live work in a
slackline Factory you probably said do
you have a job come back to the mini
trampoline oh wow that maybe has some
real validity to it like just bouncing
and suddenly you can start to understand
you mean like the one person yeah
all of a sudden you're like okay how do
I begin to challenge this vestibular
system where I am in space how do I
begin to challenge and what does that
look like well for most of us for a
middle-aged dad I can stand on one leg
and put on my socks and work that what
we found is that if we got put in some
of this more balanced play that slack
device
the balance play was enough if we like
worked it into their the kitchen and
what we saw was that we had athlete
stronger feet and better reaction times
hard to quantify it so how much is the
right amount of dose
is the second question the first
question is how do we get you started on
the dose and I think if you're out on
one skier you're mountain biking you're
walking on unstable surfaces you're
probably getting a lot of it but I think
what ends up happening for a lot of us
is that we don't get a lot of it and we
think we're experts at it until we see
the internet and we watch ourselves slip
on icy surfaces until we try to do
parkour and then you're like oh actually
oh wait a minute wait a minute here
or you go to a yoga class like go to a
yoga class
and look at how much programming is done
on a single leg and I'll tell you how
effective your program is if you think
you've got the best secret scroll
program on the planet great let's go
apply that we're going to jump into
flies class we're gonna jump into yoga
class you say Secret Squirrel Secret
Squirrel um
yeah squirrel
I wanted to bring up some notes
of other Vital Signs because uh We've we
I think we've we've covered getting up
off the floor we've covered some we're
starting to get in some physical Vital
Signs yeah physical Vital Signs so I'm
going to give you a cue and you can tell
me
where we go this shoulder airport
scanner
that's right so the first time I became
the shoulder airport scanning the first
time I became aware of this a very
clever coach named Mike Boyle
was talking about he's like you know
that yeah he's a g he's been holding the
door open for a lot of us for a long
time
and he said oh do I think the average
working adult show Olympic lift just
watch them put their arms up over their
head in the airport scanner and you can
answer that question
thank you coach Mike Paul and I suddenly
was like oh my God you know when there
you are in the airport scanner and you
have to put your arms up over your head
it's shocking to see how people solve
that little thing so we see crazy banana
backs and feeder turned out and bellies
out and elbows flared and it looks kind
of ugly and that's a pretty mid-range
position so with the airport scanner
test is really how well can you put your
arms over your head
do you have to tuck your chin like
you're in the you don't have to do
anything to solve the torture Tower
that's gonna put in a in a vice to get
your hands well one of the things that
I'll have you know is that if you go to
yoga class what is the bane of every
yoga class now we're dog resting
downward dog we're talking about with
our mutual friend
sit down who's downward dog looks more
like a plank and he's like this is not
restful downward dog is two things
putting your arms over your head that's
it and being in a long set position
sitting with your legs out in front of
you so it's almost like the yogis were
looking around and they're like we don't
have any equipment
but there's two positions that we've
found to be very valuable for people
having the leg out in front of you
sitting to 90 degrees which is is an
actual Vital sign for or a test for
physical therapists and putting your
arms over your head and if you go to a
yoga class you'll be like why are we
spending so much time with my arms over
my head and it turns out not only do we
have a healthier shoulder
but we start to untangle
seemingly complex problems around neck
pain because your neck your shoulder and
your back are a trifecta they're a
system and if one aspect of the system
isn't working or less effective or
doesn't have access to its range for
whatever reasons and one of the things
that happens as being modern people is
that we just tend to be a little stiffer
in the upper back you may not actually
put your arms over your head ever
until you're asked to even putting your
shirt on you figure out all these ways
to bend your arms and not put your arms
through over your head like a little kid
putting their arms up you may not be
hanging from a pull-up bar
if we come back to Edo portal he
prescribed hanging simple hanging for
people to improve their shoulder what
elegant programming if you suddenly are
you're an old gymnastics room they're
like why are these stall bars here
they're stall bars everywhere hanging is
a thing that really worked and came out
of all of our movement traditions
and if it wasn't hanging it was downward
dog like things the gymnast friends I
have are obsessed with walking on their
hands you are obsessed like you like to
be upside down walking on your hands
bouncing your hands so what we found was
this was a way of getting people to move
their upper backs and take a breath
there was restoring this full range of
shoulder flexion and again you don't
even have to be perfect you just have to
have more than you had yesterday and
it's a really important way to improve
the functionality of the neck
body system by honoring and looking at
the relationship between the shoulders
and the body and it's really simple so
we have you lay down on your stomach
grab a broom
put your arms over your head with
holding the broom so the broom's out
like you're like presenting the broom
light contact with your head just light
contact just don't cheat it's like
you're Superman but you're flying with a
broom yeah that's right and all you need
to do is lift that broom up off the
ground keeping your arms parallel and
guess what it's shocking when you can't
do that yeah and that's really generous
because we're allowing you to use your
upper back and we're allowed to use a
shoulder and I don't care if you're a
physical therapist you're I'm
documenting again Vital Signs this is
mid-range
and what we find is if you're not
exposed to that on the regular it can be
shocking when you're and then let's go
into Amazon and look at all the
marketplace of all the thoracic wheels
and thoracic mobility and let's beat the
crap out of your upper back with a
lacrosse ball and all of the things
you're a partially
and you're not you're not wrong it's
like when I can plan I'm like oh and
Austin's always all these Bitcoin
CrossFit Ayahuasca bastards I'm so sick
of it and people are like you made that
happen I'm like no no no no I can't take
full credits look it's very valid that
what I saw was that you were having a
hard time cleaning and jerking and
walking on your hands or snatching and
what we saw was that we improved
people's thoracic spines and overhead
if you have shoulder pain
and you know someone in your family has
shoulder pain one of the things that you
can do is to begin to just return your
body to what its native ranges are so I
can't say definitively that your
shoulder pain will go away if you
restore your ability to put your arms
over your head but there's a whole lot
of things that get better and it may be
that your brain starts to think
differently about or perceive what's
going on when it has more movement
Choice when you're able to recruit more
musculature when your connective tissue
is working better et cetera et cetera
and so again we aren't saying you have
to do this but we've come to understand
that if you're going to swim that's a
great activity we should do when we're
older right low weight bearing and super
cool but if you can't put your arms over
your head that's going to sort of
curtail yourself not only will it
curtail your swimming but if you don't
have that range of motion and you
swim regardless you can also create all
sorts of Orthopedic issues well it's
called work around so your body is going
to solve this problem for you no matter
what a couple things come to mind as I'm
listening to this the first is
a question which we'll come back to
which is for people who get face down
with the broom handle and they're like
my hands are glued to the floor or maybe
they can't even get their arms over
their head what are some building blocks
maybe some corrective exercises my
thought here because I remember when I
was working with Jersey gregoric amazing
coach
who's in Northern California uh has
several World Records in Olympic
weightlifting and I've had one shoulder
reconstructed and also just haven't at
that point had not prioritized
straight arm overhead positions so that
long lever that's right right so the
idea of doing say an Olympic snatch was
just out of the question I mean I would
have killed myself or it really required
surgery and getting stronger in the mid
back and at those end ranges which would
be I suppose exemplified in the example
you gave someone laying on their stomach
with the arms overhead holding the broom
handle and then lifting it off the
ground that is strengthening that last
few degrees
what I found is once I strengthened
those last few degrees for me right
whatever those last few degrees were but
it's like oh okay we're not going to
break automatically we're going to give
you a few more degrees maybe it's not
even strengthening it's just accessing
and using okay that's interesting we put
that software back into play so I'll
answer your question
when we're working with people
who have pain or incomplete range of
motion or after surgery
we regress a lot of movements and
regression means and here's a spoiler
for everyone
any rehab program corrective exercise
program anything you're seeing on the on
the web comes down to two things it's a
version of these two things you're going
to either go slower
that's called Tempo that's what we do
for people when we want them to feel
time under tension we just slow down it
gives your brain a chance to understand
where you are you can signal that this
is a safe position we can move slowly we
just move slower or we stop those are
called isometrics so putting your arm
over your head and taking a breath there
is a fancy way of doing an isometric
which means you're moving you're
creating tension without moving the
joint or moving the tissue Bruce Lee
style yeah and so notice that what we're
testing you here is your ability to have
some end range isometric control so very
fancy all you need to figure out is kind
of take a breath actually five breaths
because I'm interested in you being able
to breathe in that position and hold
that position because you can do a one
rep max breath hold
but I'm actually you're a human being I
need you to be able to breathe there
right
so what we can come back to is well
what's the first thing I need to do go
get a lat pull down machine for my my
living room probably not
even put a pull-up bar in my living room
no probably not let's keep Japanese
table on a tree break
let's get you to grab your sink
walk your body back into an L so you're
hinged over and just start to put your
hands again parallel close to each other
and just start taking some breaths there
and that's a you could do the wall
hanging put your hands on the wall I
don't have a sink okay you live in a
sink Society sinkless Society so if you
put your hands up on the wall walk down
walk back until you feel you can't go
anymore then just take five breaths
there the first thing that you're doing
is exposing yourself to the positions
you want to improve if we are trying to
teach a complex skill we don't just
lecture about the skill the thing we do
is say let's start the skill let's make
this skill slower so you can feel what's
going on but we need to start to expose
you to the thing if we're going to talk
about skate skiing that's super cool but
let's go skate ski a little bit and see
what happens first and could we then say
well I wonder if your lats are tied or
it might be useful to see if we could
get some sneaky ways into mobilizing
specific aspects of the movement system
get your thoracic spine to move more
effectively and this is why we actually
you have breathing as one of the
practices here because if you start to
tap into this idea of breath you can use
your lungs to get Motion in your upper
back that's so weird that you do that a
lot you showed this to me I thought you
had almost killed yourself because we
were in a sauna together because we're
doing a lot of hot cold and you took a
huge breath and then bent down over your
quadzillas for those people who don't
know these quads are the size of my
torso and hugged your own legs and
popped your
thoracic yeah and I was like holy [__]
what'd you just do there yeah I called
the Tower of London the tower and I were
traveling we saw that in the Tower of
London there was a torture device where
you were kneeling in that basically that
position
you put your chest on your legs
and then someone would screw a vice over
your back basically like a wishbone and
compress your back tell you couldn't
breathe anymore and I was like that
Christmas but I was like that's a clever
way to get into the upper back I'm gonna
try that so I went home
inspiration strikes all over the place
right always be mobilizing and uh I
discovered that that was a really
wonderful way to help get this Global
flexion of my back instead of having my
neck just hinging down I wanted to get
more total rounding of the back and
you've heard you started a little
internet fire with Coach summer when you
were like Jefferson curls are necessary
and everyone was like oh you can't round
your back you'll die you know and like
okay maybe but we do seem to round our
backs a lot and maybe something you want
to do and that Jefferson curl turns out
to be a really simple isometric that
anyone can do right if you go to a yoga
class the amount of bending over you're
gonna do rounding and then come back to
Flat show me your control and then round
again then let's see if you can extend
your back
upward nag downward dog that's going
from extension deflection so we can
again come back out of that and say well
what in your exercise program that
you're doing for fitness and really it's
not for Fitness it's usually for body
composition let's be honest are you
touching these shapes that your body
should do and if they're not you're
going to have to come up with a solution
for putting it back into your diet yeah
you know the number of times in any yoga
class that there is these slow return to
standing vertebra by vertebra
long before Thomas Jefferson ever came
up with Jefferson Crossing
long before there was uh there was a
little kid in India it was like this
really makes people better yeah
I want to give a mention to something
that was introduced to me by boss ridden
famous fighter which is the O2 trainer
which is a resistance device
that allows you to have progressive
resistance by breathing through a
mouthpiece with different types of
breathing exercises and I don't speak
for boss but I think it's fair to say
and I've continued to use this device
I've been super impressed by it and
using respiratory resistance has a
number of sets of clinical data to
support that it reduces lower back pain
and I was like that's interesting found
these studies on PubMed and I was like
that's very interesting let me take a
look at this and what boss these are all
tying together boss would indicate sort
of frontal breathing there's a
particular exercise for let's just call
it frontal breathing where you feel what
you would normally feel which is like if
you're meditating focusing on your
breath chances are it's your chest or
your abdomen but then he would round
over and focus on back breathing and he
said to me be really careful with this
he said do not do 30 repetitions off the
bodies like do 15 repetitions 15 breaths
doesn't sound like very much and he's
like you will feel like you've done a
thousand lat pull Downs the next day
your back will be incredibly sore myself
that's strange yes that doesn't make any
sense and then I did it and uh lo and
behold
incredibly sore in the back but becoming
more familiar with the anatomy of
breathing outside of the most obvious
that has been highlighted for us which
is the abdominal or chest breathing I
found to be incredibly helpful for all
sorts of things Pavel used to talk about
breathing behind the shield yeah so if
you're an Oreo cookie
you breathe into the cream filling when
you're under load yeah we want you to
have as much movement choice and options
if you're carrying something or holding
something where are you going to pick up
that breathing if you're compressed or
you're like it can't just be
diaphragmatic breathing you can't just
be and if you're running away from bears
can you breathe up in your neck I sure
hope so yeah
so one of the things that I went back
and found the original notes from the
original course we did back in like 2008
and I have a section on breathing
mechanics there and I didn't realize now
that I was just laying on gold and then
of course we have through our friend
Larry Brian McKenzie and definitely Wim
Hof homage I start to become more breath
interested and now if you come work with
me or do some of our stuff we talk like
the first intervention for back pain is
breathing it's time for my breathing to
get that diaphragm dissociated from the
psoas to get input into the movement
system because when you breathe you
extend when you exhale you flex and if
you're in bad back pain I can get you to
do a ton of small motions attached to
your breathing that your brain thinks is
non-threat and guess what it turns out
also that if we do breath holds
isometrics that can help attenuate pain
and if we do long exhales after an
isometric well that can also signal less
threat to the brain and so we can
suddenly tap in and use this breath as a
mobilization device as a diagnostic tool
we mean you can't breathe in that
position as a way of self-soothing as a
way of control when I'm stressed whoa
look at this crazy thing and that's why
look James Nester wrote a great book on
it if you look at Lauren chaitau if you
look at all the Masters I mean boutreco
shout out oxygen Advantage like people
have been beating this drum and the
yogis figure this out very early
but because it was sort of wrapped in
the language of spiritualism I think a
lot of the athletes forgot and we found
that if we thought about the mechanics
which is what you and I are talking
about here the mechanics of breath not
the CO2 tolerance or the breath control
or down regulation we're just talking
about mechanics we were able to improve
people's VO2 max you think that's
important to a world-class biker being
able to pressurize more meant that my
Olympians lifted more at the Olympics
because they could pressurize more
effectively so we started in my thinking
I started reorganizing how I was
teaching and I put the breadth volume
as the core belief core Foundation
because suddenly
it was a way of people understanding so
you can do this if you're just sitting
here take the biggest breath in you can
just go ahead
breathe through your nose and we can
actually measure that volume don't
change your position now watch this
you're doing this at home get into a
position where you think you can get
more air in
so Tim and I just both set up we pulled
our heads down we kind of organized our
shoulders and I didn't say to do any of
that I didn't say play rib cage down or
change your pelvic position I didn't say
get into shavasana with your shoulder or
tuck your chin I just said can you
breathe more effectively in that
position and you did you got into
position and you could tell better
saying worse we improved biomotor output
by organizing your body slightly
differently so now you have a powerful
tool
to bring attention to your shape so I
don't think there are good shapes and
bad shapes I'm just like well you can't
really breathe in that shape or that
shape doesn't pressurize very well or
that shape doesn't transfer so if you're
on your Peloton bike and you think
you're killing it ask yourself is there
a position on this Peloton bike where I
can take a bigger breath and you'll
start to organize your body and guess
what you'll power more effectively and
because we see better function of the
body we see better output of the body
and I think that's how we can begin to
have people feel these things which seem
like esoterica but all of a sudden
you're in a position where you could
take some breaths so now arms over your
head take a breath in that bottom
position of the squat take a breath like
we suddenly have ways to begin to
pressurize and to begin to restore just
based on the that feeling I have of
being able to take a bigger breath or
take a bigger breath or a better breath
so if I'm shrimping at my desk good that
probably feels good sometimes shrimp at
your desk then every once in a while
you're like why do I have a neck ache
and then ask yourself can I take a
breath a bigger breath in a different
position and that position tends to
transfer a little bit better
800 G I assume that doesn't mean 800
000 800 grams 800 grams so food can be a
little sensitive for people when we talk
about food with people and diets
five percent is per performance
I'm a cyclist Runner right I want to
build muscle
and the rest of it tends to be around
how do I change my body composition so
we'll start with that assumption now
here
is the non-trigger trigger warning if
you're vegan carnivore paleo vegetarian
I'm still talking to you okay doesn't
matter what you eat
we found that when I
backup didn't want to ever get near
nutrition for all the reasons that it's
complicated
it's highly individualized it's cultural
people have strong ideologies around it
and really personal identities around it
super cool I think nutrition for a lot
of people has become almost like
entertainment it's like a hobby or
religion well sure but if we get down to
you're working with me and I'm worried
about your tissue recovery or tissue
health or you're injured because again A
lot of times it comes through or we're
trying to keep lean body mass on you
because you're aging and turns out maybe
fat is a problem but keeping your lean
body mass is a bigger problem
when we actually get into how much
protein are you eating
people oftentimes do not get enough
protein
and so notice that I'm like oh you want
to eat raw bear steak you knock yourself
out you want to do plant P qriket
protein you knock yourself out I don't
care but let's see if we can establish
what a reasonable amount of that is
and again what I really like in my life
is getting something for nothing
and something for nothing in this
situation is that we found that when
people start eating more protein guess
what happened they got four so 800 grams
of protein today no
yes that would be great
for the low low price of 69.95 per month
with a free dialysis machine for the
first year that's right so we found that
a reasonable amount of protein was
somewhere between 0.7 and 0.8 and 1 gram
per pound body weight that's a
reasonable amount that's not crazy we're
not going to shock load you that's and
remember a lot of times if you're trying
to change your body composition or heal
or grow we need to make sure you have
enough protein number and so one of the
things that we found was this was an
easy way of controlling satiety and
actually making sure that people had on
board what they needed to recover and to
heal and what I'll ask you is if you
count the protein that you're growing
children are eating you might be shocked
to discover they're actually in some
pretty low to moderate protein diets
because it's hard to get kids to eat
those things okay protein aside again
however you want to do that is fine with
me if vegetarian it may be harder to hit
your protein minimums but one of the
things that we saw a lot
was our vegetarian friends would come in
with these little tendinopathies and
some of these issues and when we asked
them about the whole sort of Pantheon of
potential behaviors that went along with
that we found that they were really
under protein and the international
track and Fields folks everyone's Sports
they really have this one gram it hovers
around one gram per pound body weight it
really is ends up being a very
reasonable number that a lot of people
agree on okay which is still a lot more
than most people consume great so guess
what now you have a Vital sign yeah okay
and if you didn't nail it today you'll
nail it tomorrow so where's the 800
coming okay so this is the magic we have
seen
a dearth of fruits and vegetables eating
and this 800 grams comes from our friend
EC synkowski and EC came up with this
idea that hey what if instead of taking
things out of your diet we expanded your
diet what if I said Tim
you want to change your body composition
I'm going to have to have you eat a lot
more you'd be like well sign me up so
800 grams is 800 grams of fruits and
vegetables and it can be they can be
frozen they can be fresh they can be
cooked it doesn't matter so four Big
Apples is 800 grams right so it's not as
crazy as it says it's not as crazy stuff
uh banana is about 100 grams you can
think of it that way so what I'm asking
you to do is eat fruits and vegetables
and what we find is people don't really
eat fruits and vegetables they talk
about it a lot and they have a little
iceberg lettuce salad we've struggled to
eat vegetables here in Japan
actually not only have we struggled the
way
we went to a sushi restaurant where uh
one of one of our guides it was
fantastic native Japanese and I was
overhearing and someone's like why are
you laughing so hard Tim and I was like
well and then the god explained she said
well I just asked uh where where can we
get some vegetables what are your
vegetable options do you have vegetables
and they're like no
it says sushi on the door yeah yeah
what's the question it's not a vegetable
restaurant this is sushi restaurant so
we're agnostic about how you do that
you're like I'm a rutabaga guy cool you
want to get 800 grams of rutabaga but
buried in there are these things called
micronutrients vitamins and minerals
yeah and what also bait in there is
crucial is this thing called fiber which
most people don't get a lot of
um one of the things we've seen when we
have gone into this diet culture where
we restrict and take out it's really not
very sustainable and I have two
daughters full disclosure everyone who
aren't haven't always been the best
eaters but if I pack them full of
strawberries and apples and whatever
they want to eat fruits and vegetables
wise again fruits or vegetables if
you're like I don't eat vegetables I'm
like down cool just you do you you do
fruits that's fine
we found that there's a lot less room
for crap yeah
and all of the research is that 800
grams is about this magic number where a
lot of really good things happen to you
from a health perspective fiber
micronutrients should you eat the
rainbow sounds great let's eat the
rainbow I try to get six to eight kinds
of fruits and vegetables every day it's
kind of a game and guess what tomorrow
six to eight servings let's just say
different types oh types yeah so a grape
is one then I had some spinach and tried
to eat this diversity I think it was
Kate Shanahan of deep nutrition who
wrote that we used to eat roughly
somewhere between 40 and 50 different
kinds of fruits and vegetables every
year typical person
in America and now it's like three or
four like we just don't eat a lot of
fruits and vegetables and those two
things
and we find that we have people focus on
getting more protein getting more fruits
and vegetables there's just not a lot of
extra room for keto Donuts you know what
I mean like you're you're like holy crap
I'm really like guess what everyone
white potatoes it's a vegetable to fried
potato not a vegetable right we should
probably you have been advocating for
these very dangerous things called beans
for a long time oh boy
internet you're gonna give me a Brian
McKenzie Ted Talk on beans no beans
count towards your grams I'm like how
cool Redemption you're eating a thing
that's a plant full of plant matter and
fiber that's so great let's eat more
beans right and like I think yes of
course if you're a person who's like
beans cause me anxiety not trying to be
Beast here but if that's you your excuse
from eating beans and that's what I want
to give people permission is saying hey
I understand you don't like these things
let's what else can we open up to 800
grams of kiwi fruit do it do it do it
and you know what we found is that
if you are like I'm only going to do
this with apples you'll do that for four
or five days and you're like what else
you know kiwis are super cool uh kiwi
every day is a little bit much and again
we're looking at through this lens this
built to move lens of durability if we
keep lean muscle mass on you and get
fiber and micronutrients in you you're
probably going to feel better and do
better Long Haul and maybe we have all
the things your tissues are going to
need to repair and heal and sometimes
that is one of our friends describes the
supply chain economics of your tissues
there's a reason here in Japan they eat
everything all the collagen all the skin
all the bones everything broth
those things have been part of our diet
for a long time yeah totally so a few
thoughts for folks also on top of that
so with getting an increased volume of
vegetables fruits it may make sense if
you have the savings to do so the cash
flow look at a list called Dirty Dozen
there are certain plants that have more
pesticide exposure in the United States
totally and so you can use that to
selectively
either avoid certain things or consider
selectively buying certified organic so
that you're not dealing with
strawberries my understanding is like a
sponge so maybe spend your money on
better strawberries yeah yeah or like
stick with bananas but you don't need
the Skins that's right less Skin's not
great but you'll notice there it's easy
to demonize meat for example and I
didn't even say eat organic meat I just
said whatever you can afford whatever
works in your socioeconomic system is
going to be a better health outcome
than not getting enough protein and
fruits and missions yep so on the the
vegetables side of things most people in
the US don't think in grams and I
recognize this is an international
audience but a lot of us listeners
what's the easiest way to
figure that out here's the caveat of
course is that if you have control
issues right and this has been a problem
for you in the past don't worry I
measure everything kind of get a rough
idea of what it is right like hey look
it up you can see like what is a
grapefruit way what is this bag of
spinach is 12 ounces great I'll eat this
bag of spinach I've eaten 12 ounces
right and it's in grams there too
and if you want to have a sort of a
rough idea or wait for it did I eat
a banana this morning for breakfast plus
pineapple plus a salad plus tomatoes
that was
all the fruits and vegetables I consumed
this morning and what I do to myself is
I hate weighing things Juliet loves to
track it I don't we're different soccer
so I obsess on I should probably eat
more fruits and vegetables every meal
like it's that simple for me and I end
up when I do track it usually right
around there above and this is not that
big a deal what I'm saying is add some
beans back to your Chipotle Bowl that's
what I'm asking you to do
and you can get a really cheap scale on
Amazon or again you can just look up the
reference because what we're trying to
do is make this sustainable and what's
sustainable is gamifying tomorrow I'm
gonna I just did I was on the airplane I
did terrible at least for donuts great
tomorrow you get to play again and again
and again and again and Juliet and I
really have found that for example for
us
I don't know if you know this Tim about
me but I love sweets
on this trip I have noticed yes I have
granted Japan deep in the paint has
exceptional sweets cash out my daughter
yes Georgia Starr at texted me and said
you need to go to 7-Eleven and get a
strawberry and cream sandwich
we went to seven seven elevens until I
found that and uh fortunately that's
just one square Block in Japan so we're
just all right you're correct and I've
used this opportunity of burning lots of
calories to eat all of those strange and
wonderful Japanese sweets so for me I
have a potential for eating sweets I
love it but this morning there was no
freeliness like we're not outputting
today I didn't have any car but the
carbohydrate I had today was in fruits
and vegetables on my on my plate and
what this does is it expands what I'm
eating every day and it leaves me less
room for toast it leaves me less room
because I'm full and I'm trying to play
this health game yeah and I am obsessed
the thing I fear the most for my own
body right now at age 50. is
tweaks of soft tissue that's the thing I
fear the most tweaks of sausages like
pull a muscle tweak a tendon like a
little hot spot tendinopathy like you
know plantar fasciitis like I do a lot
of things to keep any of that at bay
that's how I'm viewing my tissue Health
if I have tissues that are more robust
and are loaded regularly and decongested
I'm less likely to be taken out with my
sore shoulder so you're about five years
ahead of me I guess I'm 45.
you mentioned gray cook and
the functional movement screen FMS and
he's and he has certain movements that
are used to diagnose what
would you have me do it doesn't have to
be I mean we're not necessarily going to
go through it physically right now but
if if I were to say all right
Kelly I want to be hard charging nothing
crazy but like still have the capacity
to go out with my most athletic friends
around the same age and have physical
Adventures I want to do that multiple
times a year yeah what are some of the
screens that you would put me through
the most important thing would be show
me how you're loading your tissues
that's the first thing I don't start
with an assessment the assessment is the
thing
so we're going to Press today no matter
what but we're just going to limit your
range of motion overhead and we may slow
down we may not snatch but we're going
to go overhead in some way or another
people who can't go overhead off and can
hang from a pull bar oh wait I assess
programming because people ask me to
look over their programming a lot as I
look at key positions what are we call
them archetypal shapes they're sort of
the bookends
or reference positions for your body
and the shoulder is actually not that
complex it only does like four really
things they're variations that moves
between those things but it goes over
your head
goes out in front of you goes out to the
side wait for it goes behind you that
explains all complex movement of the
shoulder some combination
you may not actually touch some of those
end range positions but you should have
access to them and what's cool about
range of motion is it's actually one of
the few attributes of your physicality
that doesn't have to change when you age
it doesn't mean that you have to lose
your ability to flex your hip bring your
knee to your chest who cares about that
lower yourself to the ground to poop in
the toilet get up and down off the
ground so this is a highly trainable
aspect so one of the things we want to
do inside your resistance training your
loaded movement training which is
unfortunately you're gonna have to do
you know we have the very end of the
chapter of the book we have a little
chapter called never do nothing so Dave
Spitz of Cal strength is like never do
nothing he's old like me he's really
busy has a family and he's like well
some days I just did like some pull-ups
in the garage that's what I got today
never do nothing
and
ultimately if you want to then say Okay
I want to be durable Kell
and I want to have the opportunity then
some of these behaviors range of motion
things you could do if you didn't have
access to exercise they can help you
create a foundation then we are all at
Basecamp and that's why we call Basecamp
behaviors then you and I are saying well
hey I want to go up Everest and now
we're our Everest is Ken we ski six days
in Japan and not implode and come out
intact
then we can work backwards and say what
exposure should we need and by skiing I
think you mean it mostly in the way that
Laird Hamilton famous bigwave surfer
said they should call surfing paddling
because it's 90 paddling by skiing we
mean mostly sliding up mountains I don't
know if you've noticed it it's not only
the oldest but I'm also the largest
one of our guides is akin to Legolas
like she doesn't even deform the snow
when she stands on yeah she can run
across the snow yeah and I'm like Hey
we're not the same animal right now I'm
a snowplow
you are an Arctic hair
[Music]
um so ultimately
if we start with this root pattern shape
this idea of this well I call it the
archetype then you have a master key of
understanding any movement structure any
physicality any system because what
you're ultimately seeing is different
tools to challenge fundamental position
shapes if you're a gymnast you may be
walking on your hands and swinging from
a bar overhead if you're Olympic lift
you're you're lifting overhead maybe
you're in the gym doing lap pull Downs
you're going to yoga you're doing
downward dog you're on the reformer
suddenly you're like oh okay there's
everyone says being overhead is
important and here are all the different
ways to train that and I'm probably
going to need to do some resistance
around that some kind of progressive
loading and again we can have now
nuanced conversations how strong you
need to be to do what we did I don't
know how durable do I want to be I want
to be all the durable
so I think one of the things that is a
fair criticism of fitness
is that we have convinced everyone to
basically become Doomsday Preppers where
you're never strong enough strength is
never a weakness you're never fit enough
or uh that is crazy one of my good
friends has this idea now he's like
maybe we should not call it functional
fitness which is sort of a scarcity
mindset we sort of calling it practical
Fitness can you do what you need to do
and if you're saying I need to ski up a
mountain for two hours and descend in
-10 degrees that's a different set of
circumstances than I want to walk around
the block of my baby but the kinds of
training ultimately we're going to need
to put you under some load how to do
that
simple loading for someone who's
listening it doesn't like to exercise
could be jumping there's an old like
Russian saying when you stop jumping you
start dying this Chinese say you're as
old as your spine or as old as your feet
and again if I got those wrong please
you can correct me you can correct him
but the idea here is
there are fundamental truths about how
we load do you remember in the 90s Every
Woman suddenly was osteoporotic they all
everyone had osteoporosis and they're
like you need this calcium chew and we
sold calcium shoes to everyone in
America and it didn't change the bone
density of everyone because we didn't
change the loading of anyone so
ultimately for you as a middle-aged
person I need to make sure that you have
control through these things so we would
do more strict kinds of movements and
suddenly you're like oh wait a minute
that looks like classic strict
gymnastics training that looks like
classic barbell training that looks like
simple kettlebell training like some of
these strict push-ups I have taught on
every continent except Antarctica and
everyone knows what a push-up is and
what the bench press is everywhere so
it's like training and movement is the
fundamental common movement language
so now we can say well what tools do you
have what's your training experience but
ultimately we need to do something that
goes up and down and rhymes with a squat
how you want to do that you want a
goblet squat you want to back squat you
want a full snatch you want to squat to
a chair
there's a really famous test in physical
therapy called the timed up and go
and it's you stand up out of a chair you
walk 10 meters you turn around you sit
back in the chair we can time you that's
a power they're measuring wattage
because you can put a clock on that and
it's a really good indicator of fault
risk lifanov one of the most famous
Hammer throwers in all time used to
front squat 200 kilos for seven and then
run 400 meters
that's the same test
so you can see
same test those are very different
extremes but that's the same thing
so you and I can have a polite
disagreement about how big and strong
you need to have how much we fetishize
and need to be in the gym develop the
capacity and how much we need to spend
other time becoming more skillful or
more springy or playing and I think we
have and as I said it's a fair criticism
of
strengthening Edition gym culture that
we have obsessed on these gigantic huge
bodies big French presses right it's
easy to quantify that there's a famous
coach named bonder Chuck who is one of
the greatest throws coach in the whole
history of the world and he's like
you're probably strong enough I know you
can add another kilo to the bench but
what you need to do is go throw more
it's more fun for a thrower to add a
kilo to their bench than to go throw
some implements more times
so one of the things that has worked
well for me and some of the older people
is that we're always challenging
position remember that root idea of the
gym is that we're challenging positions
and shapes in fact your brain isn't
wired for musculature it's wired for
movement so a shape is really just a
snapshot of a movement so squatting up
and down is a movement that we need to
challenge so we can change the variables
where are you holding that help raise
your torso
how fast are you going
but can also not just make it heavier I
can also say well like what we did I
need you to walk up this hill for two
hours blow yourself out and then I need
you to squat all the way down how well
you can handle that squat under some
metabolic demand there are some times
where I post hold up to my like waist
and I had to do a steep one leg Squat
and my heart weighs at 190 already yeah
and I was like whoa how do I train for
this yeah right or you're going really
fast in chesty powder and then you stop
and chesty pattern you're like my legs
are stuck my legs how do I yeah I need
camel camel hip flexors to get this so
it turns out just being stronger though
in that moment doesn't actually solve
the movement problem does you need to be
competent with the skilled movement
under cardiorespiratory demand breathing
hard under metabolic demand a little
fatigue there are real loads out there
real loads we're fighting like I was
like well I'm really glad I'm I have a
big butt doing this right there was a
skill component to it and so suddenly we
can what's really great about viewing
the training of shapes
is that it allows you to have permission
to do what you like to do and so instead
of saying my hard style your non-hard
style right we're not fighting that you
think that this is the kind of train
that really speaks to you that puts you
in a community that hits these things we
can test the veracity of your training
by dropping in over here and seeing how
well you do you should be able to jump
into pilates class you should be able to
handle that if I hand you some dumbbells
you're like okay I can do that I don't
care for this it doesn't matter if
you're the strongest at dumbbells or
pull out his class but you should be
able to transfer those skills back and
forth
and now rinse wash repeat
for a few decades
and what you'll find we have a simple
test in the book we talk about squatting
of course because I love squatting but
turns out squatting is one of the ways
to restore your back and to get flexion
in your spine this big butt ass to Grass
squat it's a nice test of hip range of
motion ankle range of motion balance but
for those people who can't we say hey
let's squat to the chair and then today
if you've never squatted before you can
do one Squat and tomorrow you're gonna
do two squats and the next day you're
gonna do three squats in a row and
you're just gonna build up for a month
and guess what's gonna happen after 30
days of doing 30 squats in a row your
life is going to change but we just have
to begin some Progressive overload for
some of these things totally so if I
were thinking about the last couple of
groups of foreigners I've come with to
Japan and I'm painting along National
lines let's just say and this will tie
then into the question of age groups I
could look at just let's limit it to
this group and how people look trying to
sit the way we are sitting right now
there are plenty of things that other
people in this group plenty of things
they can do that I cannot just to be
very clear I have to be good at sitting
on Japanese floors
there's some incredible athletes on this
trip but they're bad at sitting on the
floor right so I could think all right
maybe that like external rotation of the
femur is something as a group
they might want to pay more attention to
just as an example sitting in a
cross-legged or one leg on top of the
other position which they can't
currently do
if we were to take a paint a very
specific picture so let's just say
former athletes not high level athletes
I mean I'm basically talking about
myself right so I can competed at a
decent level through high school and
college in various things
was never world champion was never a
Olympian anything like that but it was
very movement immersed and then trained
very very seriously and then let's just
say between who knows 35 and 45 maybe
the training got a little lighter maybe
it got a little more sporadic
and this is the group we're dealing with
right so let's let's just these are
these are my people yeah so let's just
say we have 145 year olds who kind of
mirror that like me we got to make some
pains maybe they've had a couple of
fractures maybe one or two surgeries
that's the group much like looking at
this group that came to Japan and saying
huh seems like a lot of these guys have
trouble sitting
with their legs sort of splayed open in
any way in that type of
kind of post-competitive athletic group
that I described was to make some pains
and some injuries are there any
particular types of movements I know
this is kind of question that you may
hate but I'm just curious if there are
any particular types of movement
training that come to mind where you're
like you know I think that group should
overall be doing more of
a b and c I think we sold hard
cardiorespiratory to Fitness
that is you had lungs like Lance
Armstrong all things would be solved and
it's easier to quantify that because you
can go wattage you can count and look at
heart rate and Power
let's say the biking and again Juliet
and I are huge cyclists we love to ride
them and writing is great for these
reasons
very time efficient and it's what we
call High physiology low skill put your
feet here put your butt here grab the
hands here you have five points of
contact very safe mid-range not full leg
flexion not full knee flexion not full
hip flexor just gonna move around
and we can die you can die I can kill
you on that thing like pour hate on you
and you can suffer and vomit on the bank
and when you think is wow that was
really hard now I'm Fit until you need
to move yourself through the environment
a little differently and I think we've
confused
work output we've confused some of the
cardiorespiratory capacity
if I took the criticisms from some of
the big thinkers who reacted to CrossFit
on it striking Edition Bros they have
some valid ideas here how well are you
actually challenging this and using this
in the world and now the question is how
much Fitness is the right amount of hard
Fitness and shouldn't I play
and is there anything wrong with going
to the gym every day for an hour and
smash yourself no
but if you're all you're doing again
having some Vital Signs one of our my
favorite vital signs in the book is
called the couch stretch and here's why
you should care about the cap stretch
one is you're gonna find out that you
suck at it you're welcome and all you do
is you put your knee into the corner of
the wall you're on your hands and knees
kind of facing with the wall and you put
your knee into the corner where the wall
meets the floor and then just bring the
other leg up into a lunge squeeze your
butt your leg back leg is bent and
you're in a lunge position using the
wall to support that
that is a shock to people because their
quads are stiff or their brains
protecting whatever the mechanism is
they can't access that position they
can't squeeze their butt in that
position they can't take a breath in
that position they can't even hang out
in that position and that is a easy
position to be in
but if your environment doesn't cue you
in to also being a diagnostic tool
regularly
because your body is so robust and so
badass and so good at working around
these things for so long it's designed
for survival you know your brain doesn't
care if you're missing hip extension but
that hip extension is you walking up a
hill having that knee behind you when
you walk or run or lunge that shape what
goes away faster than anything with
movement quality and capacity is
compromised in this Society more than
any other movement
is that hip extension why well we do a
lot of cardio on the bike the elliptical
machine was genius because it just
removed hip extension entirely you could
stand up but you don't have to take your
hip extension congratulations
and all the sitting we do is modern
workers and the commuting and we're sort
of cued and so we just don't get a lot
of exposure here and again if you
dropped into Pilates you're like whoa a
lot of hip extension and if you eat yoga
like there's a lot of warrior one like
why are we doing this long lunch at a
chaturanga it's because they recognize
this is a position we wanted to nurture
and if I could say wave my magic wand
and say I would like you to spend more
time in this position suddenly you can
still squat but you just do a Bulgarian
squad or a split squat right you instead
of pressing what barbell over your head
is why don't you put your front foot up
on something and press I want you to
push a sled oh that sounds familiar
we've seen that like that's out in
culture
and when we again
stop talking about the capacities but
look at the shapes first then it's all
like what tools do I have available to
me how can I do this throwing your foot
up on the edge of a couch and jumping
out into a big lunge nailed it and let
me give you an example we regularly work
with really good athletes and teams who
have these deficiencies I've worked with
several Olympic lifting Olympian groups
who don't do enough hip extension and
when all we did was start programming in
hip extension for them these shapes of
being in like a lunge lo and behold
everyone's back pain got better and
their lips went up so weird and so again
what I want to do is say let's make sure
that we're not confusing capacity with
movement Choice yeah because I think
that goes away really fast what we've
said we can have really strong very open
quotation marks fit people who aren't
very skilled at moving yeah so how's my
fitness I don't know I just had to
balance on one leg put my ski on and
they The Binding I didn't love on the
side of a mountain right after being
smoked so let me tell you how my fitness
is like that's the test yeah yeah
totally and for people who want to get a
visual on the couch stretch you can
certainly just give it a search on
Google but if you imagine the capital
letter
n
and then put like a little circle in the
very middle of that the left side of
that would be your front leg and the
right side of that would be the rear leg
with the knee in that corner and it's
also in for our body yeah it is it is
indeed that's how long I've been saying
you should be doing the count stretch it
is it isn't and we're we're I think I
think you're demoing on an actual couch
I've been demoing on our couch and our
our old couch back when we both had a
little more hair
I don't even know how much hair I had
then
you know um
one of the things that I just want
people to hear is that we're trying to
build an extra capacity to the system
and oftentimes the initiation for a lot
of the reasons why people are interested
in this is paint or I can't do something
that I want to do my friends are going
to Japan and I can't ski or not from the
skill but my knee hurts that's a problem
so where do we begin to tug do I have to
go hire an expert and go seek this thing
and go away from my family and take time
off from my job that's a yes great cool
you can afford that and fly in your
private physical therapist to work with
you that's doesn't seem that scales very
well right and what we instead can do is
say hey look here's things that you can
do
in the course of your day and this
really right or wrong you know Juliet
who is our CEO my partner world champion
Superstar she really felt attacked a
little bit sometimes when people talk
about their morning routines and all of
the things they did to optimize their
day and biohack their day
and she's like I'm so swamped and this
really feels unaccessible to me feels
like a bunch of single people with a
bunch of free time right
and interestingly enough the thing that
I ended up kind of getting out of PT
school by looking at was barriers to
adherence what keeps people from doing
what they want to do and one of the
things that we started to recognize as
we work with some of these groups is
that we couldn't just say do this we had
to say when are you going to do it how
do you fit it in so all the things we've
talked about are wonderful but if you're
a person who has a life you have to ask
where are these moments where I'm going
to be able to fit these key behaviors
and I think that's one of the things
that we've really started to appreciate
and say that you know we need to do a
better job of showing people where
they're going to have some agency and
control The Karate Kid approach
put on your shoe standing on one foot
you've now I haven't been training yes
you have yeah you just don't know that
you have show me
oh man why don't you tell people a bit
more about the book and who it's for
right who's who is it who is it
written for who's the best suited to
imagine that one of the things that we
Julie and I felt like was that we as
Fitness and again part of the fitness
machine and wears a Coggin machine is
that if we ask ourselves how are we
doing if Fitness is the promise is to
transform society and make people
healthier are we living up to that
and what we really feel like is well the
objective measurements are let's look at
obesity or diabetes or
chronic pain or persistent pain or
injuries or surgery or depression and
what we see is that I think 100 of those
things are trending in negative ways so
if
Fitness is a trillion dollar industry
and we're not making people fitter
and whatever expanding the fitness
besides I look great on Instagram with
my abs right just expanding that
definition a little bit then we have to
start asking sort of a different set of
questions around this
So This Book Is For Whom potentially
Fitness has left behind who hey I don't
identify with exercising cool that has
nothing to do with being durable think
about how many people on there when we
were in some of those towns we saw some
elderly people here how fit were some of
those elderly Japanese people they
didn't bench press a lot I don't think
her deadlift was very strong that 90
year old we saw right but there's
something about being durable and being
useful however we're defining that that
there is a set of things you have to
keep doing that your body just requires
and then we can layer on exercise if
that feels good
so imagine the first thing order of
business is saying hey look let's get
everyone to base camp and then we can
argue what color rope you should take up
the Everest route because that's I feel
like that's the conversation on the
internet and people are like wait wait
what's base camp what's Everest the
number of people that stop us in our
community remember Jill and I are just
parents in our street and they're like
hey do you think I should do this keto
shred and what do you there's a lot of
questions we get where people are don't
know how to be sustainable they don't
know how to exercise because we've
overwhelmed them
with options and choices and data and
flashy signs so if we can get built to
move into those hands first or how about
this you love Fitness you're into this
stuff I'm into this stuff
and I have always wanted a reference
maybe like start here it's not that
exercise well just have a go at this and
then let's talk let's sum up when you're
ready to have learn how to smooth
kettlebell or your physician who says
hey I know you're on this blood pressure
medicine and this isn't the place to
have these complex
psycho emotional behavioral
conversations in this eight minutes but
here's something you can do we know that
it's going to make a healthier more
robust platform and we gave this book to
our world champion friends and we're
like how do we do and they were like
this really helped me because I had some
holes here that I wasn't thinking about
I wasn't walking enough and I was
wondering why my knee was hurting and
it's trite to say who's this for I want
Julian and I really want to make sure
that we've reached out to people who
haven't been served well by the fitness
Community because what we see is that
those people who are in it looks like a
classic Society in terms of fitness and
health now people are measuring and
monitoring and tracking and like getting
fitter meanwhile everyone else is saying
hey I don't even know where to start
I would also say tell them if you
disagree with this but a lot of folks
probably who think they are being served
by whatever
form of Fitness they're consuming
when they get taken out of a very narrow
band of fill in the blank cycling fill
in the blank powerlifting fill in the
blank some form of bodybuilding once
they're thrown into
an environment that is a little more
stochastic requires movement patterns
that are a little more varied they're
like oh [__]
our friend Mark Bell couldn't put a shoe
on without sitting down and using a shoe
horn when I first met him yeah there you
go
Champion yeah but couldn't put a shoe on
yeah we wore like his shoes were always
tied now look what happened to Mark yeah
you know as an idea of I think that's
really a grade and we might even say we
have some vital signs to help you
identify your blind spots and I think if
we have always right or wrong we've
always said if we can give people the
tools
the right people the right tools they
know how to incorporate in their lives
and make the change you have seen that
I've seen people come up to you and a
hundred times and say that you change
their life and you're like I've never
met you you know sir this is a Wendy's
you know but given the tool people are
smart enough to have figured that out
and that's what we want to do you don't
know what you don't know this is a
really simple way and I want everyone to
understand this is what Julian and I do
and this is what we have been sort of
winnowing out of our Elite Performance
conversations with
all the crazy teams that we work with
Kelly we've covered a lot of ground
built to move is the book I suggest
everybody check it out because we are
built to move
turns out that this fancy brain of ours
is
scaffolded around this machine that is
intended to move through space
and I think the diversity of our
movement diet much like the vegetables
and skull and love that from dozens down
to just a handful yeah and there's no
way that it doesn't end in tears
right individually and collectively so
I'm really excited to have
the set of vital signs the descriptions
the means of self-assessing to identify
blind spots areas of opportunity growth
opportunities growth opportunities which
I'm very excited about because this trip
for me
has been decades in the making in a
sense and I've always wanted to bring
some of my closest friends to Japan and
to train I mean I really trained my ass
off for the last six weeks more than six
weeks but especially in the last six
weeks to make sure that I wouldn't be a
total embarrassment and it was still
hard I mean it was still hard
and I was like okay
45 it doesn't seem impossible to me I'm
not going to be Laird Hamilton but it
doesn't seem impossible to me that if I
approach training
in an increasingly intelligent surgical
way with regular self-assessments that I
could be doing this stuff 10 years from
now if I play the cards right but like
to play the cards right you got to know
what the game is what's in your hand and
I think built to move will help people
to do all those things any other closing
comments requests of the audience
anything you'd want to point people to
anything at all they'd like to say
before we go have a gigantic Japanese
lunch three things one
be consistent for your heroic yes like
excellent advice two wait for it the
glacial praise is the Breakneck Pace it
takes time to make change your body is
there for you it just may be that you
have to put the burning tractor trailer
out of fire first before you back it
down the blind alley like it takes a
second but it always works and three
you're not alone bring someone with you
on this adventure if that means just you
walk down after dinner
and that was what you started for this
week grab one of your family members we
think that the living unit is the
functional unit of change that's where
you begin so bring some along with you
Roger that
thanks for bringing me along with you
I'm gonna have to go into some
counseling for uh before round two
dragged up this health
there you have it folks Kelly always a
pleasure thank you Tim and to everybody
listening we'll have links to everything
in the show notes as per usual 10. Blog
podcast just search Kelly Starrett
s-t-a-r-r-e-t-t there are many episodes
this will be the most recent of course
and built to move is the book check it
out until next time be just a little
Kinder than is necessary that includes
to yourself remember be consistent
before heroic good advice for a lot of
things whether that's writing walking
hanging squatting down to take a heroic
poo in a Japanese bathroom you never
know when you're gonna need that skill
facts facts and thanks so much for
tuning in talk to you next time
hey guys this is Tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet Friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bold Friday easy to sign up
easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that I send out every Friday to
share the coolest things I've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles I'm reading books I'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that get sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcasts guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then I test them and then I share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about if
you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.com Friday type that into your
browser Tim dot blog slash Friday drop
in your email and you'll get the very
next one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by eight
sleep temperature is one of the main
causes of poor sleep and heat is my
personal Nemesis I've suffered for
decades tossing and turning throwing
blankets off pulling the back on putting
one leg on top and repeating all of that
ad nauseam but now I am falling asleep
in record time why because I'm using a
device it was recommended to me by
friends called the Pod cover by eight
sleep pod cover fits on any mattress and
allows you to adjust the temperature of
your sleeping environment providing the
optimal temperature that gets you the
best night's sleep with the Pod covers
Dual Zone temperature control you and
your partner can set your sides of the
bed to as cool as 55 degrees or as hot
as 110 degrees I think generally in my
experience my partners prefer the high
side and I like to sleep very very cool
so stop fighting this helps based on
your Biometrics environment and sleep
stages the Pod cover makes temperature
adjustments throughout the night that
limit wake-ups and increase your
percentage of deep sleep in addition to
its Best in Class temperature regulation
the Pod cover sensors also track your
health and sleep metrics without the
need to use a wearable so go to
eightsleep.com Tim allspelled out
eightsleep.com Tim and save 250 on the
eight sleep pod cover that's
eightsleep.com Tim eight sleep currently
ships within the US Canada and the UK
select countries in the EU and Australia
again that's dot com slash Tim to save
250 on the eight sleep pod cover-up
this episode is brought to you by
Shopify Shopify is one of my favorite
companies out there one of my favorite
platforms ever and let's get into it
Shopify is a platform as I mentioned
designed for anyone to sell anything
anywhere giving entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so what does that mean that means in no
time flat you can have a great looking
online store that brings your ideas
products and so on to life and you can
have the tools to manage your day-to-day
business and drive sales this is all
possible without any coding or design
experience whatsoever Shopify instantly
lets you accept all major payment
methods Shopify has thousands of
Integrations and third-party apps from
on-demand printing to accounting to
Advanced chat Bots anything you can
imagine they probably have a way to Plug
and Play and make it happen Shopify is
what I wish I had had when I was
venturing into e-commerce way back in
the early 2000s what they've done is
pretty remarkable I first met the
founder Toby in 2008 when I became an
advisor and it's been and spectacular
I've loved watching Shopify go from
roughly 10 to 15 employees at the time
to 7 000 plus today serving customers in
175 countries with total sales on the
platform exceeding 400 billion dollars
they power millions of entrepreneurs
from their first sale all the way to
full scale and you would recognize a lot
of large companies that also use them
who started small so get started by
building and customizing your online
store again with no coding or design
experience required access powerful
tools to help you find customers Drive
sales and manage your day-to-day gain
knowledge and confidence with extensive
resources to help you succeed and I've
actually been involved with some of that
way back in the day which was awesome
the build a business competition and
other things plus the 24 7 support
you're never alone and let's face it
being an entrepreneur can be lonely but
you have support you have resources you
don't need to feel alone in this case
more than a store Shopify grows with you
and they never stopped innovating
providing more and more tools to make
your business better and your life
easier go to shopify.com Tim to sign up
for a one dollar per month trial period
it is a great deal for a great service
so I encourage you to check it out take
your business to the next level today
and learn more by visiting shopify.com
Tim one more time shopify.com Tim all
lowercase
[Applause]